[Musique]
c'est après la mort du héros connaît la
légende celle de Ernesto Guevara plus
connu sur le nom du Che ne faillit pas à
cette règle comme toutes les légendes
elle s'appuie sur une réalité qui
devient peu à peu à mon imaginaire où le
héros n'est plus un être vivant mais à 8
une vie médiatique et une mort jeune ont
suffi à transformer l'image du Che en
une icône symbole de toutes les
révolutions
[Musique]
il a eu une enfance effectivement une
enfance bourgeoise mais pauvre c'était
des c'était avant l'heure ses parents
étaient avant l'heure des bobos comme on
dirait aujourd'hui des bourgeois bohème
et ils étaient très bourgeois et très
beau même un père plus ou moins
fantasque anarchiste une mère élevée
chez les bonnes soeurs une famille très
bourgeoise mais qui n'avait pas trop
d'argent et qui étalait s'installer dans
la cire à Cordoba au milieu de
l'Argentine sèche à cause d'un handicap
considérable de leur fils aîné
Ernesto qui n'était pas encore
Ernesto Che Guevara à savoir l'asthme ce
gamin qui était touché TIF très très
maigre
il ne sortez pas sa mère utilisait la
broceries c'est-à-dire la sorcellerie
pour essayer de le sauver puisque la
médecine ils suffisait pas aller
chercher des chats noirs enfin tout un
tas de choses qu'on mettait dans son
dans son petit lit et puis
à l'âge de 5-6 ans
foutu pour foutu lâchons-le et c'est ça
sa sœur qui m'avait dit à l'époque on
l'a laissé sortir comme un oiseau qui
sort de sa cage et lieu de tomber de
cette cage il a réussi à s'envoler c'est
à dire que il a profité de la vie il a
fait du sport et monter à cheval il a
commencé à tirer au fusil à nager
mais il avait une telle ténacité telle
force que il a d'abord dominé son asthme
et il faut bien comprendre la place de
l'asthme dans sa vie parce que il
faisait durable quoi en fait c'est
asthme l'avait failli l'enlever tout
petit et toute sa vie il en a
terriblement souffert donc en dominant
cette asthme là il est il est devenu
quelqu'un d'une ténacité extraordinaire
étude secondaire
il fréquente la bonne société bien que
encore une fois il n'est pas beaucoup
d'argent mais leurs parents sont
tellement
connus que on les on les reçoit un peu
partout et puis lorsqu'il termine ses
études secondaires il revient à Buenos
Aires il fait tambour battant des études
de médecine
et avant même de terminer ses études de
médecine il s'engage avec un copain qui
était plus âgé que lui grenado dans un
grand périple latino-américain
[Musique]
j'aurais très bien pu aller au pyramides
visiter les pyramides venir à Paris
faire faire d'autres choses que de
découvrir leur propre continent mais ce
qui est intéressant dans leur cas c'est
que ils sont restés sur leur terre de
l'Amérique latine sur la pachamam la
Terre Mère des Incas il y a deux points
forts dans ce voyage qui deviendra
initiatique le Machu Picchu parce que il
est confronté avec cette civilisation
précolombienne et en tant que descendant
d'espagnol il pense à ses civilisations
passées qui ont été détruites donc là
ils en veut aux Espagnols qui ont
détruit ces civilisations et après
Chucky Kamata il en veut aux Américains
qui mettent en esclavage ses
contemporains de l'Amérique latine
ils ont découvert donc cette pauvreté
terrible endémique avec un choc dans une
mine qui s'appelle Chucky Kamata en haut
du Chili un lieu où naissait et mourait
les gens c'est qui était à la merci
presque en esclavage des maîtres qui
étaient des Américains donc là il a
commencé à avoir un choc et une
réflexion
agrémentée d'une chute sans importance
pour l'intégrité de la moto notre
équipée s'y poursuivi en direction de
Saint Martin de Los Angeles alors que
nous étions sur le point d'arriver et
que je conduisais nous avons encore
mordu la poussière dans un joli virage
couvert de gravats et bordé d'un
ruisseau au doux murmure cette fois la
carrosserie de la peau des Rossa a subi
des dommages suffisamment graves pour
nous obliger à nous arrêter en chemin et
pour comble du malheur c'est à ce moment
là que survenu l'un des accidents que
nous redoutons le plus la crevaison à
l'arrière dès qu'il revient à Buenos
Aires il termine ses études de médecine
il obtient son diplôme et quelques
semaines après aussitôt il repart pour
un deuxième voyage et cette fois ça va
être le voyage sinon définitif en tout
cas le départ définitif de l'Argentine
[Musique]
il a connu une jeune péruvienne dans le
genre un peu pétroleuse pas très belle
mais très militante qui développe chez
lui un marxisme qui devient très très
vif très fort à un moment donné même il
envisage d'aller dans la Chine de Mao
et puis le voyage ne se fait pas mais
pour d'un poil bon il reste à Guatemala
et c'est là qu'il assiste à une
manifestation de l'impérialisme des
États-Unis en grandeur nature ou
Guatemala en 1954 il y a eu un
instauration par militaire nationaliste
de gauche d'une réforme agraire qui a
été combattue là aussi par layona était
de full Tom par une grande compagnie
américaine qui produisait des bananes
cette réforme agraire à débouché sur un
renversement du colonel arbaisses au
profit d'un débarquement faut monter
depuis les États-Unis tout cela pour
expliquer qu'une seule chose
Ernesto Guevara et sur place à l'époque
il assiste au débarquement des
mercenaires depuis
appuyé par les États-Unis il essaye
d'organiser un peu la résistance avec
des gens du Parti communiste guatemaltes
le rapport des forces et beaucoup trop
en faveur des Américains il entiera des
leçons très importantes sur la manière
dont il faut se préparer si on veut
réellement faire une révolution
conséquente la manière dont il faut se
préparer à une intervention militaire
des États-Unis il entière des leçons sur
la nécessité de la formation de milice
populaire il reste un mois planqué à
l'ambassade d'Argentine au Guatemala et
bientôt organise son départ il va se
réfugier à Mexico
[Musique]
il tombe à nouveau sur des exilés
cubains qu'il a connu au Guatemala qui
sont passés du Guatemala oh à Mexico et
ce sont ces exilés cubains qui lui
présentent d'abord Raoul Castro et puis
un mois plus tard fidèle Castro qui est
un ministère qui arrive à Mexico
[Musique]
avec l'un des États-Unis il se lance
dans l'aventure un soir de novembre 1956
il s'entassent à 80 dans un petit yacht
qu'ils ont acheté d'occasion et Fidel
Castro est tellement impatient il va
débarquer dans un endroit qui n'était
pas prévu où on n'attendait pas c'est
plutôt un naufrage un vrai débarquement
[Musique]
et légèrement blessé et il a abandonné
le choix entre un sac de médicament qui
doit prendre ou bien une caisse de
munition il peut pas prendre les deux à
la fois il choisit la caisse de munition
à partir de ce moment-là il déclare j'ai
décidé plutôt que d'être médecin d'être
le militant révolutionnaire et le
guériro que je nécessite depuis lors
l'aviation de bâtisseurs les attend ils
sont bombardés c'est aussi une fois de
plus de nombreux morts mais ils sont
sauvés parce que sur place il y a des
gens qui les attendent qui les aident il
y a une douzaine une quinzaine de ces
expéditionnaires qui arrivent à
rejoindre la Sierra Maestra qui est une
petite montagne où la végétation est
tellement épaisse que il est très
difficile de les retrouver
[Musique]
dans la sirène Maestra la Révolution et
la lutte s'organise autour de Fidel
Castro et d'Ernesto de Che Guevara le
chier devient alors une figure
emblématique de cette révolution que
Fidel Castro sera utilisé pour son
compte
[Musique]
figure populaire de la révolution en
marche il devient le plus célèbre des
commandants
le
et son goût du sacrifice qui est qui
était lié à l'asthme le cette espèce de
jansénisme cette espèce d'ascétisme
qu'impliquait un régime très sévère le
tuer donc s'est révélé à un combattant
remarquable il s'est montré le meilleur
et le plus fou le plus audacieux presque
inconscient du danger fidèle a fait
Ducher le premier commandant de la
Révolution Cubaine c'est-à-dire avant
son propre frère Raoul ce qui est une
marque d'estime bien évidemment
extraordinaire et le chat est d'une
bravoure il était téméraire il était
presque trop et fidèle lui disait mais
on a trop besoin de toi va pas te faire
de flinguer reste un peu reste un peu
derrière reste calme-toi calme-toi
il entraîne ses hommes à des actions
complètement héroïques et folles
cela étant il faut préciser que le
nombre des combattants dans la cérama
estra n'était pas énorme
ce qui en revanche ces manifesté c'est
que lorsque les colonnes du Che et de
Camille aussi un fuegos ce sont mises en
route à ce moment-là elles ont commencé
à drainer un certain nombre de paysans
pauvres qui les ont rejoint
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
p
au fur et à mesure que l'armée rebelle
remporte des combats militaires contre
l'armée de bakistan elle mène de manière
simultanée une politique dans la
montagne très efficace et très
intéressante et qui en particulier est
réellement menée par Che Guevara qui
consiste à implanter des écoles dans la
cérama estra dans la montagne des
hôpitaux ils ont des tentes de campagne
mais on soigne les paysans on les
alphabétises quand on peut on fait très
attention à la relation qu'on a avec eux
c'est comme cela que peu à peu à la fois
on démontre l'efficacité de la guérilla
face à la dictature mais aussi c'est
comme ça qu'on gagne un soutien social
alimentent dans les villes un
développement des mobilisations
populaires
est parti à la tête de colonne de
guérilla pour s'emparer d'une ville
centrale dans l'île Santa Clara c'est un
exploit parce que il se trouve que le
Chill avait jamais mis les pieds
auparavant et la première fois il va
aller à Santa Clara et bien il va
appliquer une tactique militaire qui va
lui permettre de s'apparer
partir de ce moment-là l'armée de
Batista c'est la débandade c'est une
armée qui va se décomposer et descendre
58 le dictateur s'est envolé et la
révolution est victorieuse
[Musique]
victorieux les révolutionnaires
libérateur de régime du dictateur
Batista entre dans la vanne sur des
chars acclamé par une foule en liesse
Ernesto de Che Guevara ne cessera dès
lors de prendre une place de plus en
plus importante dans la vie politique de
Cuba devenant ministre de l'Économie
puis de l'industrie
[Musique]
le dieu arrive à la vanne auréolée d'une
réputation de grands commandes Fidel
Castro a toujours été un peu méfiant
envers tous ceux qui pouvaient avoir
trop de
prestige d'un prestige qui aurait pu lui
faire de l'ombre alors il demande à
Guevara de s'occuper de la forteresse de
la cabania qui domine le port de La
Havane et où se trouvait
emprisonné
auparavant c'était des révolutionnaires
et après la victoire de révolutionnaires
ça a été les sbires de Batista
[Musique]
c'est Guevara que Fidel Castro charge
d'organiser les jugements contre ces
prisonniers de Batista ce n'est pas un
simple épisode de
l'histoire du tiercé probablement la
tâche la plus indélébile que puisse
avoir ce personnage les
cumin qui ont tué à faire à lui à ce
moment-là
et
les membres de la famille des fusillés
l'appelaient
c'est-à-dire le petit boucher de la
cabane
sous ses ordres ont été exécutés des
dizaines de prisonniers avec
des procès ridicules qui duraient
quelques minutes une heure ou deux les
gens étaient fusillés pendant la nuit
envoie des gens non jugés par un
tribunal donc c'est lui qui était chargé
de
d'accomplir les exécutions
des personnes qui avaient été comme
d’années les premières c'était des gens
qui avaient été conformis avec le régime
de Batista et compromis dans la dans la
répression mais bientôt ça a été des
contre-révolutionnaires l'acte violent
de résistants pour moi de mon point de
vue à une légitimité et je rappelle
quand même qu'elle est point de vue de
votre point de vue les français
puisque vous n'arrêtez pas de chanter le
louange Jean Moulin et les quelques
résistants alors voilà donc l'acte
violent de résistant est une chose mais
quand vous êtes au pouvoir
fusillé 300 personnes c'est d'un crime
l'épisode de la cabania révélera la face
la plus sombre du Che
bien que portée par de fortes valeurs de
justice sociale il n'hésite pas à faire
fusiller des centaines d'opposants
condamnés lors de simulacre de procès
comme l'exécution de l'ancien chef de la
police du dictateur Batista
[Musique]
il y a des auteurs qui ont prétendu que
Fidel Castro était déjà communiste avant
pour ma part je le crois pas je crois
par contre que s'agissant de Guevara
c'est quelqu'un qui avait
véritable connaissance du marxisme mais
sans avoir été membre d'aucun parti
communiste
ignore encore qu'il est devenu
communiste ou marxiste il s'est marcisé
surtout au contact du check pendant la
Siam Maestra et il a demandé l'appui du
Parti communiste cubain parce que le
Parti communiste Hubert a une espèce de
verticalisme disciplinaire ce qui
n'était pas le cas avec les troupes même
de Fidel Castro donc Castro s'appuie sur
le Parti communiste uber ce qui se passe
dès 59
c'est que face aux attaques qui sont en
train de se préparer de la part de
Washington la direction
révolutionnaire en particulier Castro et
guevaraz cherche des appuis et là je
pense que l'expérience du chewbacée
voilà a été très importante cherche des
appuis face à ce qu'ils comprennent très
vite c'est à face à ceux qui va être une
rupture avec qui semble inéluctable et
rapide avec le gouvernement américain et
ses appuis ils vont les trouver où et
bien ils vont les trouver à Moscou et
c'est seulement après un an de guérilla
diplomatique et économique et politique
avec les grandes entreprises des
États-Unis que le voile a été levé et
que Castro s'est déclaré ami de l'Union
soviétique et partisans d'un système de
socialisme collectiviste que les
Américains ont très vite taxé de
communiste
Cuba dans le discours qu'il a prononcé
en dépit de sa maladie au premier con
jeunesse latino-américaines il a annoncé
l'expropriation et la nationalisation
des compagnies américaines de Cuba cette
décision touche des affaires telles que
la compagnie cubaine d'électricité les
os standards et la Texaco dont la valeur
s'élève à quelques 400 milliards
d'anciens francs nouvel épisode dans la
tension americano cubaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les États-Unis décident d'en finir avec
ce dangereux individu et ils organisent
mal un débarquement à Cuba persuadé que
la population va se rallier aux
contre-révolutionnaire qui débarque
fidèle Castro avec Guevara et surtout
les fronts c'est le fameux fiasco de ce
qu'on appelle la baie des Cochons de
Playa Cullen on va s'apercevoir qu'il
n'est pas si facile de se débarrasser de
fidèles Castro et final gastronomie à
partir de ce moment-là se tourne d'une
manière délibérée vers l'Union
soviétique pour demander l'appui de nous
ce petit
la manière dont l'économie
a été traitée à Cuba
ça fait penser c'était des apprentis de
sorciers et le tierce était mis dans la
tête
le mot d'ordre de Lénine industrialiser
le pays parce que la canne à sucre
signifie une sorte d'esclavage et puis
de aussi de fatalités
mono-producteur donc il fallait que ça
industrialise sauf que il y avait pas de
matières premières et de même que tu
avais c'est en train de détruire
actuellement l'industrie pétrolière au
venezuelienne le tiercé acharné et
détruire l'industrie sucrière de Cuba
ils ont une trentaine d'années un peu
plus de 30 ans quand ils sont au pouvoir
donc être au pouvoir à cet âge-là
pourquoi pas mais enfin s'il y en a un
seul ça va mais quand ils sont tous de
ce stage là il manque quand même
quelques aînés pour équilibrer certaines
choses
pour gouverner quoi donc ça n'a pas été
toujours très simple cette histoire là
il s'est retrouvé économiste du jour au
lendemain
c'est plutôt un poète c'était plutôt
été plutôt Don Quichotte que
que quand de banque donc c'était pas
simple pour lui mais il s'est mis au
boulot à fond
[Musique]
cette révolution est chevellée cette
révolution qui exaspère les Américains
des routes les Soviétiques eux qui
s'affirment expert en révolution sont
dépaysés devant la fantaisie cubaine
devant cette fièvre devant cette façon
de mettre la charrue avant les vœux
en moins de deux ans Cuba est devenu
plus socialiste que l'URSS après la
réforme agraire la réforme urbaine et
les nationalisations voici que les
Cubains ont décidé de faire de 1961
l'année de l'éducation l'un des premiers
résultats de ces mesures c'était et que
le biais le pesos humain qui valait 1
dollar c'était
la parité absolue autrefois mais il a
perdu toute sa valeur lui-même
reconnaissait c'est et c'est lacunes
dans sa formation économique mais tout
d'un coup il s'est mis en théorisé il
signait les billets de banque ça fait
partie de la poésie et du romantisme
toute l'histoire mais c'était c'était
fait avec grand ieux parce que ce
monsieur là n'était pas n'était pas
qu'un plaisantin quoi c'est sûr il y
avait de grands débats sur
les principes qui étaient adoptés en
Union soviétique et puis et les
principes que lui développait
c'est-à-dire c'était les stimulants
matériels contre les stimulants moraux
autrement dit mais les stimulants
matériels qui étaient adoptés en union
de soviétique et que les plus réalistes
des communistes cubains
pensaient pouvoir adapter et c'était bon
on donne un peu plus d'argent où on
donne des biens de consommation aux gens
pour qu'ils travaillent plus non le Jedi
c'est non non simplement des stimulants
moraux qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire de
simulant morront l'on se donnait un
petit fanion on leur donne une médaille
comme quoi ils étaient travailleurs
d'avant-garde et qu'ils étaient à la
tête de
du premier territoire libre
d'Amérique latine
ment ça n'a pas marché
[Musique]
il y avait
l'idée que la société pouvait créer une
société révolutionnaire pouvait créer un
homme nouveau on leur demande de
travailler sans relâche en leur demande
de travailler le samedi de faire du
travail volontaire le dimanche on leur
demande d'être impeccable au point de
vue moral et au point de vue spirituel
en leur demande d'être incorruptible
exiger des Cubains qu'il fasse ce
travail dit volontaire et beaucoup de
cumin n'y allez pas avec grand plaisir
parce que ils avaient déjà leur boulot
habituel et là sur leur
moment de repos le dimanche ou en fin de
soirée ou il fallait qu'ils aillent
bosser pour le pays en plus donc c'était
pas toujours bien vu mais le check comme
d'habitude montre l'exemple et il fait
les efforts physiques qu'il faut pour
montrer l'exemple quoi cet homme qui
travaille rien pour lui tout pour les
autres il y croyait parce que c'était un
utopique sa fameuse phrase qui est
merveilleuse soyons réaliste exigeant
l'impossible il en rêvait il a vu qu'il
marcherait pas au moment de l'invasion
quand il arrive dans un dans un village
et qui dit
un jour pendant qu'il était en Algérie
on lui a demandé
un article pour une revue
révolutionnaire une revue de gauche
uruguayenne Marcia et il a envoyé un
long article qui est devenu un petit
opuscule révolutionnaire qui a servi un
peu de Bible à beaucoup de
révolutionnaires dans le monde entier
qui s'appelle le le
socialisme l'homme et la Révolution et
là il faudrait si l'on veut analyser à
quel point un révolutionnaire peut aller
jusqu'aux extrêmes analyser ce texte qui
déborde dans le lyrisme exagéré et le
sacrifice sans condition
cette asthmatique était prêt à tous les
sacrifices et il exigeait des autres
également tous les sacrifices
[Musique]
les dirigeants cubain heureusement non
pas eu finalement une très grande
responsabilité dans la crise et
les dirigeants fidèle castrent en tête
et voulait envoyer de façon préventive
une amicine nucléaire sur une grande
ville américaine c'est ce qu'il a écrit
noir sur blanc en équitacle
ça a été un coup de folie soviétique
parce que c'est des Soviétiques qui ont
installé les fusées mais quand ils ont
vu ou cela pouvait mener ils ont dit on
va retirer les fusées
mais le quai assumer complètement ma
position d'envoyer une arme nucléaire
sur une grande ville américaine et de
provoquer un holocauste mondial c'était
dans la logique de ces conceptions mais
c'était surtout dans la logique du
conception de Fidel cast il ne faisait
que suivre son mentor
mais surtout final Castro a été
extrêmement vexé de s'apercevoir que les
discussions entre kruchev et Kennedy se
sont passés ce sont déroulés au-dessus
de sa tête
il y a il en est résulté à un certain
froid avec l'Union soviétique mais à
partir de ce moment-là déjà l'économie
cubaine commencé à battre de l'aile
et
il fallait
compter sur l'aide économique de l'Union
soviétique et des pays de l'Est
[Musique]
et donc fidèle a été obligé de composer
alors que Guevara qui au début était
complètement ébloui lui aussi par
l'Union soviétique avec une espèce
d'admiration un peu inconditionnelle lui
aussi en revient et il va y avoir
une différence
sensible mais lente qui va se manifester
entre fidèles et le Che jusqu'au moment
où le quai qui était le
porte-parole en quelque sorte de Cuba
c'est lancé dans une diatrie
[Musique]
anti-soviétique j'allais dire anti
anti-impérialisme soviétique ce jour-là
Che Guevara ira trop loin on entendra
même construire en coulisses les
délégués soviétiques il dit quelque
chose que jamais un pays socialiste ou
on voit vers le socialisme nausé dire à
savoir que les pays socialistes ont le
devoir de payer
en armes et en matériel les pays du
tiers-monde qui veulent se libérer et
non pas de
leur vendre du matériel des armes etc
comme c'était le cas pour l'Union
soviétique et les pays de l'Est qui
vendaient des armes de retour à Cuba la
confiance laisse rapidement place à
l'inquiétude dans le regard du Che
et c'est finalement la tête baissée
qu'il vient la rencontre de Fidel Castro
et d'osvalo dirty COS alors président de
la République
derrière les sourires de façade la
tension est palpable Castro cherche du
regard se fissent qu'il a déçu mais le
tchédétourne les yeux sous le poids de
la cuisine silencieuse
à partir de ce moment-là Guevara
disparaît complètement de la circulation
c'est la dernière apparition publique et
Guevara comprend qui n'a plus sa place à
Cuba
[Musique]
c'était un révolutionnaire il voulait la
porter dans le monde entier c'était sa
mission quelque part c'était son
urgence et sa vie donc on l'envoyait au
Congo dans une zone un peu neutre
surtout pas tout de suite en Amérique
latine qui est mais dans une zone où
personne
qui dit oui dérangerait pas les Russes
en fait d'où son départ au Congo une
mission complètement
[Musique]
grotesque puisque on retrouve au Congo
personne n'était préparé pour une
guérilla il y a une espèce de de côté
désert des tartare de Dino Buzzati
c'est-à-dire que ils sont là ils
installent un camp d'école de guérilla
mais il ne trouve pas d'ennemis
véritable
alors il démarre que là et il veut
rendre rationnel la révolte congolaise
mais d'après ce que lui il pensait que
de la rationalité et il n'a jamais donné
le mal de comprendre que effectivement
dans tous les actes
sacrificiels mystique des Africains il y
avait une raison c'est à dire que donc
on voit là son volontarime voilà son ses
côtés très dangereux de révolutionnaire
qui parce qu'il croit avoir raison tout
lui est permis il y a quelques escars
mouches et finalement les Rangers belges
et départ des Américains qui les avaient
informés les coins et là il se rendent
compte que la seule solution est de
s'enfuir que cette guérilla n'a servi à
rien
[Musique]
on commence à se demander mais où est le
qu'est devenu le check fidèle pour se
débarrasser du problème va rendre un
mauvais service à débarras d'une manière
délibérée ou pas la question se pose
encore il va lire en public en octobre
1965 une lettre d'adieu que le ciel lui
a laissé
espérance déconstructeurs
cette lettre disait des choses un peu
bizarres que le thé renoncé à toutes ces
fonctions et Alsa nationalité cubaine et
le loge de fidèle de manière très
directe alors c'était un petit peu la
victime qui faisait l'éloge de son
bourreau
et c'est une victime consentante
par la suite si on en analyse si on
analyse cette lettre on s'aperçoit que
les termes qui sont employés dans cette
lettre sont souvent
des expressions semblables à celles qui
étaient employées par les victimes les
prochaines Moscou la lecture publique de
cette lettre
était une condamnation à l'exil
éternelle du duché mais dans la
mentalité de fidèles les gens font des
erreurs mais à partir du moment où ils
continuent à être désinconditionnel il
peut leur pardonner et c'est ce qui est
arrivé il a pardonné aussi il a permis
que le thé revienne à cumin et qui
l'organise son expédition pour partir en
Bolivie c'est à dire qu'il meurt en
martyr
qui meurt en martyr c'était
le
plus beau cadeau qui pouvait lui donner
[Musique]
avec le concours de fidèles il forme un
commando de 16 personnes 17 avec lui qui
sont des cadres du parti communiste
cubain des gens qui ont été ministres
vice-ministre etc pour former une école
de Guerriero qui à leur tour devait
aller porter la bonne parole
révolutionnaire au Pérou au Brésil en
Argentine au Chili il se retrouve un
rôle non le Nyan kawassos c'est à dire
moi j'y suis allé
il y a personne il y a pas de paysans ou
très très peu qui sont peureux
les le suivre or il y a pas eu un seul
paysan qui est rejoint la guerrière pas
un seul
la Bolivie était un pays aussi qui avait
connu une réforme agraire or la base du
programme politique du quai c'était la
réforme agraire
les paysans dans une certaine mesure
appuyer
et les gouvernements c'est un pays qui
avait des qui connaissaient des coups
d'État c'est le pays qui a connu le plus
de coups d'État
en Amérique latine là où c'était
irrationnel c'était des prétendre que
dans un pays aussi politique
ou les syndicats avaient une telle force
croire que parce qu'on allait dans un
petit groupe de guérilla à planqué dans
une forêt les choses allaient rayonner
à la manière cubaine mais le tien lui il
avait gardé
l'expérience cubaine il a débarqué dans
un pays qui connaissait pas
il a toujours ignoré tout le travail
politique préalable qui avait été fait
par Castro à Cuba et à partir du moment
où manger Mario manger qui était le
secrétaire de
du Parti communiste bolivien avait reçu
les ordres de Moscou toujours à Moscou
suite à la lettre donc ça c'était très
important à comprendre que le Parti
communiste ne voulant pas de cette
guérilla mais après elle était voué à
l'échec développer la Révolution
américaine si ça réussissait c'était
très bien pour Cuba
mais c'était aussi une manière de se
débarrasser du tier c'est sûr que ce
qu'il devenait et qui pouvait devenir un
comburant
et s'il mourait bah il allait avoir un
héros qui pouvait exploiter
[Musique]
au Congo et puis il a très vite compris
qu'il était en Bolivie
et surtout elle en a une incertitude
lorsque Debré s'est fait attraper avec
le pain de argentin silo boost
c'est seulement lorsque la présence de
ce petit corps expéditionnel a commencé
à être détecté par l'armée bolivienne et
par des agents de la CIA que la guérilla
a été obligée de faire que la guérilla
du tiers a été obligée de faire
mouvement et qu'elle a commencé à
circuler dans la région une région
qu'elle ne connaissait pas où il n'y
avait pratiquement personne à convaincre
puisque c'était le désert c'était une
région extrêmement hostile et entre
décembre 1966 et le mois d'octobre
1967 ça a été une espèce de guérilla
sans admis qui n'ont pas cherché le
contact et quand ils l'ont cherché ils
n'ont pas trouvé jusqu'au jour où des
paysans les ondes dénoncés
c'est une extricable j'avais pas de le
destin était scellé là c'était fini pour
moi c'était fini dès le moment où Moscou
a dit à manger le secrétaire tu laisses
le check sans bourber dans l'histoire tu
ne touches à rien tu vas pas chercher
les guerriers de l'autre côté après
c'est la logique de terrain c'est fini
j'y suis allé c'est Pelé on peut pas
qu'on peut pas il y a rien pour se
cacher c'est pas simple c'est pas ça du
tout et ils ont quand même été
extraordinaire en se plantant dans les
ravins enfin ils ont ils ont tenu le
plus possible comment le thé fait-il
laisser prendre vivant
alors on a raconté que
son fusil
ne marchait plus
probable ce qui s'est rendu
ce qui dans mon optique n'en fait pas un
lâche mais finalement un être humain ce
n'était plus un héros il n'avait plus
une volonté de martyr ils avaient envie
de vivre
et il était persuadé qu'il allait
survivre
pourquoi parce que il y a immédiatement
des photos qui ont été prises qui ont
été diffusées vous voyez le thé est
vivant d'autre part il y avait le procès
de Régis Debré et de cilomoust
dessinateur est peintre argentin à
Camille en Bolivie avec une
médiatisation internationale et des
interventions de certains gouvernements
au niveau mondial notamment celui du
général de Gaulle en France et au moment
où il a été capturé il a cru qu'il
allait qu'il allait s'en sortir en
ressortir vivant et je pense que le thé
vous lit un procès vous voulez un procès
où il aurait développé toutes ces
théories puis toute sa profession de foi
mais les Boliviens ne l'entendaient pas
de cette façon
alors là il faut faire une différence
entre la CIA les Américains et les
boliviens
la Sévigné ne voulait pas
tuer le thé pourquoi parce que il savait
les Américains savaient qu'on le tuyau
ils en faisait un martyr les militaire
bolivien s'en fichait complètement
l'ordre est donné de l'éliminer il faut
choisir qui va appuyer sur la gâchette
et donc il décide de faire un cadeau le
cadeau mais c'est comme ça que ça lui
sera présenté
un jeune adjudant terrain qui est le
jour de son anniversaire
tu vas te payer le chier et le gars
rentrent et au sport donc il va boire il
revient et puis il lui met des tirs mais
c'est pas c'est pas réussi donc c'est un
gars de la CIA qui est là qui lui donne
le dernier coup il a été exécuté dans un
village de montagne de la Hera et
transporté en hélicoptère jusqu'à
weglandais
on l'a étalé sur un banc de buanderie
[Musique]
le Chey est mort
à la manière d'un trophée le corps du
Che est exposé à la foule qui vient voir
de ses propres yeux le cadavre du plus
célèbre des révolutionnaires
ces images feront le tour du monde dès
lors la figure du chei ne cessera d'être
utilisé comme symbole des luttes
révolutionnaires et le vent sont
personnages au rang de véritables égérie
des idées marxistes les ministres
[Musique]
pour nous la mort d'une chaise a été un
événement énorme moi je sais qu'à Paris
on a dû être les seuls sans nous vanter
on a fait un grand meeting dans la salle
de la Mutualité il y avait 2000
personnes pour nourrir le check on
s'était vraiment pour nous quelque chose
d'important puis il était mort en
Bolivie c'était l'internationalise on
souvient encore des de toute l'attitude
du check expliquant que pour aider le
Vietnam fallait créer un deux trois
quatre Vietnam donc tout ça c'était un
langage nouveau que les vieux bronze
communistes alignés utilisaient pas bon
c'était vraiment une raison de plus pour
notre génération d'autant plus qu'à
l'époque on rentrait en opposition avec
les dirigeants du PC on était en train
de se faire virer notamment on était
contre le stalinisme on pensait qu'ils
étaient trop nationalistes pas assez
internationaliste le tuer pour nous
c'était vraiment le modèle c'était
vraiment l'idée de la deuxième action
l'idée quand même des
voilà on va pas faire une vie
triste une vie une dimensionnelle une
vie bon voilà alors les représentait ça
est-ce que les tirs représentait ça
abusivement est-ce qu'elle est cheat
était à Marseille de léninistes carrées
et nous on s'est trompé d'icônes bon moi
je pense que oui ou non les tiens
personnages pour ce que je puisse avoir
été quelqu'un de assez corrigé mais bon
peu importe n'est-ce pas ça c'est la vie
personnelle mais en revanche c'est vrai
que par rapport au réalisme socialiste
un art par rapport à la libération
sexuelle que pour nous c'était très
important par rapport au féminisme par
rapport à l'attaque contre la famille
l'antipsychiatrie donc par rapport à
cette mouvance là c'est pas possible et
identifier les chees avec cette élan
désirante comme ça très libertaire
c'est un mythe que lui-même a essayé de
forger dès le départ même si vu comme un
héros
de la libération de l'Amérique latine
mais surtout
ces fidèles Castro qui a très vite
compris ce qu'il pouvait faire
[Musique]
vivant n'intéressait plus il voulait
s'en débarrasser mais par contre mort ça
devenait quelque chose d'extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
je crois que si le tien n'avait pas
existé Castrol aurait inventé je veux
dire par là que le
check a rendu infiniment plus de
services encore j'ai l'impression à
Castro mort que vivant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
immense portrait du check qui maintenant
domine la place de la Révolution par est
invité les Cubains à toujours plus
d'efforts et de sacrifices
mort il continue de vivre le moindre
village s'ouvre sur son effigie en
couleur naïf un immense panneau parmi
les champs permet qu'on voit sa face des
hauteurs
[Applaudissements]
on arrive à 89
la chute du mur de Berlin et les
Soviétiques qui disent à Cuba bon il
faut il faut grandir et il faut devenir
indépendant économiquement et c'est là
où la figure du check avait été un
sevelit même ce livre n'était même plus
ces
œuvres complètes par exemple on pouvait
plus les consulter dans les
bibliothèques à cubain donc tout d'un
coup
on reprend le mythe Guevara c'est-à-dire
l'homme est stoïque l'homme qui était
pour les pour les comment dire les
contre tout intérêt monétaire et que
tout devait être basé sur la morale
révolutionnaire les stoïcisme donc du
coup ils deviennent nécessaires tout à
fait utile même 40 ans après bon voilà
les morts
désintérêt et réintégrer c'est à dire
fidèle
40 ans après il trouvait comme un qu'il
était déjà assez mort comme pour pouvoir
le transporter à et faire un beau soleil
terrible c'est parfait l'image du Che et
et à m'y donner
impeccablement organisé tous les élèves
des écoles cubaines le matin disent
c'est rémuses comment elle tient nous
serons comme le check on peut
transformer le check en Unicode une
espèce de Vercingétorix de la révolution
en réimprime des billets de 3 pesos qui
rappelle l'époque où le check a été
président de la Banque centrale de Cuba
etc enfin on vend des t-shirts on vend
les porte-clés il y a toute un marché de
la bimbeloterie de Duche qui est qui est
mondial l'image du check le poster de
Korda a fait le tour du monde et aussi
célèbre que celui de Marilyn Monroe on
ne peut pas parler du mythe du métier au
passé il est toujours vivant il est
partout sur des T-shirts de manifestants
mais aussi de gens qui vont danser la
salle alors que le tien n'est jamais
dansé la scène sa vie c'est le symbole
de Cuba alors qu'il n'était pas humain
c'est une erreur de casting
sans aucun doute cette icône là il
correspond à l'époque une dimensionnelle
que nous vivons c'est d'ailleurs il y a
que l'image qui compte et derrière
l'image bah derrière les vaches personne
sur la multitude des jeunes qui ont le
t-shirt parce que quand on en voit
partout dans le monde je leur demande
c'est très rare tomber sur un jeune qui
sache qui est Che Guevara et pourquoi tu
portes ça ah c'est la révolution il y en
a qui disent ça et c'est quoi la
révolution c'est [__] le bordel bon ça
va pas très loin en 68 c'était les
portraits de Mao Lénine Marx qui Staline
les gens vivaient avec des portraits
avec la référence était la révolution
russe le 17 aujourd'hui vous regardez
les manifs de jeunes à Paris à Berlin à
Rome etc il y a un portrait qui reste et
c'est le check et le check reste
aujourd'hui pour des bonnes raisons à
mon avis c'est qu'il incarne justement
l'idée de la révolution de
l'internationalisme du refus de la
bureaucratie bon qui pour moi sont
vraiment des valeurs très bonnes très
très justes alors après elles sont
tellement bonnes ces valeurs que comme
toujours les capitalistes essayent de
faire du business là-dessus et alors
maintenant il foutent le tuer partout
mais ça va leur retomber sur la tête
j'espère
le légendaire portrait réalisé par le
photographe cubain Alberto Corda fera le
tour du monde présentant le Chey à la
manière du Christ puis Andy Warhol le
magnifique à nouveau à la façon de
Marilyn Monroe deux icônes parmi tant
d'autres qui disparurent bien jeunes
véritable
[Musique]
icône révolutionnaire idéaliste le Che
est devenu le symbole de toutes les
luttes à travers le monde
son implication acharnée et la constance
de ses idées font du Che l'unique figure
à Carnon aujourd'hui les idées marxistes
car même si Ernesto chez Guevara a été à
l'origine d'acte violent par
nécessairement légitime l'image
romantique du Guerriero a su les chasser
de la conscience collective
[Musique]